we're the tailoring Eddie you have
worked together we have oh wow yeah it
was a decade ago I once died in his arms
in a in a screen test for Les Mis no I
did not know this I did not know this
yeah that there's a lot that people
don't know about this story
um basically I was I was auditioning for
two roles in Les Mis and I'd done a few
auditions and gone to New York and
whatever and I think it had been
established that I I had more of a look
of cozette but I had the range vocally
of eponine so it was established that
like I was there for a good time not a
long time
I'm gonna get this role but they were
like you know do you want to come to
London for one last screen test and
you'll get to screen test with Eddie
redmay and I'm like this seems like an
experience I want to have in my life
you're like one of my favorite actors
you're so ridiculously talented
I was like so yeah I'll go to London
I get there and they're like okay so we
really want to like make you look like
eponine we're gonna try to do it's the
you know she she did she wasn't like
loaded she had Brown teeth you know like
she didn't have a lot of money so a 19th
century Street yeah we are trying to say
it in a way that makes sense but it
didn't floss exactly they were like
and I'm like so you're gonna do that
after I have to write Eddie Redmayne
right that's
that's not something you do before I get
to meet people and then you do the brown
teeth I'm like oh no it
this is just everybody's gonna meet you
with the brown teeth and we're gonna
we're gonna like do like big circles
under your eyes like like you're near
death and
I was like this this has immediately
become a nightmare for me and so then I
have you know we you were so nice but I
think when I met you I was like
it was hilariousness I you know as you
walked in as a 19th century French
street urchin and and and I was not
expecting that but my overwhelming
memory of it Taylor was I had
um I'd just been to Pizza Express
beforehand and I've had some some garlic
dough balls
I thought we were going to be singing
off with each other you know that but
they they had us also it was so weird
because Taylor was dressed fully as
eponine and I was like in my tracksuit
and they had us on the floor like
singing Sweet Nothings into each other
and all I knew is I just had garlic
bread
tea
recipe
you were weeping and I just thought it
was because of how I looked
I have to be close to her right now this
is yeah this was not the method no no
it was a beautiful
[Music]